you have to jump so high and get so much
momentum just off of like one little
half turn visiting the world of Cobra
Kai gives us some strong nostalgic Vibes
with a keen attention to character
Dynamics and plenty of fun fight
sequences this Series has been a hit
with audiences but it's not an easy task
putting all of these ingredients
together stick around for the hardest
scenes to film in season 5 of Cobra Kai
number one that's gotta hurt if you were
to ask Tanner Buchanan which scenes were
the most difficult for him to film
during season five of Cobra Kai he might
say all of them and he might say this
because Tanner spent most of this season
with a pulled hamstring fortunately for
the actor and his fellow castmates
professional Physical Therapy was a
regular part of their experience when
they weren't on set The Show Must Go On
number two sometimes you feel like
you've just hit a wall other times you
feel like the wall hits you Cobra Kai
season 5 actor Peyton List found herself
in a challenging scene to film when her
character is instructed by her teacher
to keep striking at a brick Peyton said
there's a scene where silver played by
Thomas Ian Griffith tells me to keep
hitting a marble brick that was
definitely the hardest scene for me to
do I remember crying in the middle of it
when they said cut because I just wanted
to do justice to the scene the scene is
a big moment in the story as her
character is trying to prove her loyalty
to COBRA Kai but we think her commitment
to the scene is proof enough for us
number three sometimes you can't stop
Cobra Kai season 5 actor Courtney
hengler was filming a scene with Martin
Cove it's an emotionally charged scene
where hengler's character is meant to
deliver a powerful slap to cove's
character at the end of The Exchange
having completed at least one take
already Courtney felt like she could do
one better and so asked the team if they
could try just one more take she must
have really been feeling this take
because when it came to the slap moment
Courtney rushed the timing and actually
hit Cove across the face hangler trusted
her instincts explaining because if you
stop number four this has gotta hurt
while Cobra Kai often finds the teenage
characters involved in physical
confrontations with one another there is
a certain intensity around filming
scenes when two adults get into a fight
season 5 brings us an intense fight
scene between actors Daniel Larusso and
Terry silver and even though both these
actors are martial artists Ralph Macchio
said that filming this scene was a
challenge for him well the prep for the
first fight with silver in episode 5 was
a lot more that was a much bigger meal
it was a whole day and it was a lot it
was pretty intense and Thomas is a
martial artist and he's six six or five
whatever I'm reaching up with every one
of them no one is eye level but with
Thomas it's tough he's got those long
arms and legs coming at you number five
at the top of Peyton List's hardest to
film list you might find her audition
the challenges for Peyton began during
her condition when she was tested on her
knowledge of karate and was asked to
memorize a fight sequence Peyton
admitted that when preparing for her
audition she had no idea her character
would be doing any fighting in Cobra Kai
she was given only 45 minutes in the
audition to memorize a fight sequence
and as someone who has no prior martial
arts experience we think she's done a
fine job after all she got the role
number six Billy's abka and Martin Cove
have thrown plenty of kicks at each
other but while filming another intense
fight scene this particular kick turned
into something different according to
the fight choreographer zabka threw a
kick at Martin but Billy pulled his
hamstring we think a pulled hamstring
would be enough to put this scene on
Billy's most difficult to film list but
there's more when Billy's kick came in
contact with Martin's foot the impact
broke Billy's toe jamming the bone up
into his foot Billy stunt double offered
to step in and finish the fight sequence
but Billy just pulled the bone back into
place and asked if they could keep going
what a true number seven this would hurt
anyone at the top of sholomeraduena's
list for worst scene to film in Cobra
Kai season 5. we could expect to find
this one while filming a fight scene
with fellow actor Tanner Buchanan cholo
received an accidental kick to the face
which would be enough to make filming
this scene challenging but there's more
sholo had braces at the time and this
poorly timed stunt accident resulted in
the brace wire going right through his
cheek fortunately for him he said I
couldn't feel the wire through his cheek
that is until they had to pull the wire
back through before patching him up
ouch just another day at work for sholo
number eight the stunts don't stop we
might expect that the challenges of
filming Cobra Kai would involve more
than a few bloopers in their stunts but
this one was unexpected while filming
this fight scene the stunt involved
throwing the stunt performer to the
ground but on this particular take he
hit his face on the floor as we might
expect this stunt performer lost some
teeth in this accident but no one was
expecting that they would be false teeth
they had lost a few teeth in the past
and had them replaced with artificial
ones if you have any experience with
having teeth replaced you know it can be
expensive so when this martial arts
mishap went down the cast on set began a
hunt for the missing teeth we're gonna
guess this was the first time any of
these actors had to do that onset number
nine just a little further Jacob
Bertrand describes his characters Dojo
Showdown with Kenny as the most
difficult scene for him to perform
saying I do this big like jumping called
a fe long it's like a crescent with the
butch kick and it's all in mayor um that
was really really hard for me to get
down I don't even think I could do it
right now I stretched out and like the
conditions were perfect it was just hard
and you have to jump so high and get so
much momentum just off of like one
little half turn yeah just hearing that
description has Us in over our heads how
he did it we'll never know but we love
to see it number 10. he worked and he
worked and he worked Tyron Woodley had
to deal with splitting the long days and
late hours on set with the three in the
morning training sessions for a
real-life mixed martial arts fight
that's right Woodley was shooting stunts
and scenes with the Cobra Kai cast where
they would try not to hit each other and
then after shooting was done he'd meet
up with his trainer and practice trying
to hit people so we're guessing whenever
he had some spare time there was an ice
bath involved like ow number 11. say
hello to another installment of stunning
stunts and mis-timed mishaps one of the
performers who frequently found
themselves out of luck with injuries was
none other than Mary Mouser more than
once she found herself on a physical
therapy routine to recover from
stunt-related injuries all the while
having to carry on with shooting the
next episode on this day of shooting
Cobra Kai season 5 Mary injured her hand
while performing a block during a
choreographed fight requiring physical
therapy and we can still find traces of
this injurious mishap in some scenes
where if you look carefully you can see
Mary's fingers are taped together as a
brace number 12. sometimes you just
can't get your day started the right way
this was one of those days for Cobra Kai
actor Mary Mouser when she started her
morning with a strain injury to her
ankle by just getting out of bed Mouser
spent most of her time in physical
therapy if she wasn't shooting
understandable considering all the
action yet somehow she still makes
everything look sharp on camera we've
gotta say it Cobra Kai season 5 hits
hard just watching this list makes us
feel like we need an ice pack and a
tensor bandage but we think if you were
to ask any of the performers if it was
worth the struggle they would say yes
and we're thankful for their hard work
and dedication so what do you think
would be your most difficult scene to
film and why let us know in the comments
below